[Music]
these lines are taiwan's 14 underwater
internet cables that connect the island
to the rest of the world
[Music]
in August China held military drills in
these six zones on top of some of this
critical infrastructure
and while Beijing hasn't said these
cables are a Target China's increasing
military activity in the region is
putting this vulnerable connection at
risk if the communication was not able
to function very well during the wartime
that will become a disaster
so here's how taiwan's internet is under
threat and what the island is doing to
beef up and defend it
submarine cables are bundles of fiber
optic lines about the thickness of a
garden hose 98 of international internet
traffic goes through them and the cable
surrounding Taiwan play a critical role
in connecting the asia-pacific region to
the web North Asia to South East Asia is
need to go through either go through
Taiwan or nearby ocean a lot of
countries will be certain it will be
impacted if Taiwan cable has a as an
issue Kenny Huang runs the Taiwan
Network information center a non-profit
that works with the government to
coordinate cyber security research and
response everything relied on the
internet
so the importance of Submarine just like
the blood to our body but this
infrastructure is precarious even when
there's no military activity nearby
fishing in other Maritime activity can
damage the cables especially in the busy
seas around Taiwan and natural disasters
like earthquakes or typhoons are capable
of disabling multiple cables at once
that happened in December 2006 when an
earthquake in Taiwan cut several cables
drastically restricting Communications
across Asia during the earthquake I
remember telecommunication company they
are only able to maintain some portion
of their voice call the data
communication was very poorly mentored
and security analysts say this
infrastructure could be particularly
vulnerable to being damaged or disabled
on purpose
conflict between Taiwan and China
and they are very high possibility
enough the initial tactic could be a
capable station these dots are taiwan's
landing stations the places where a
submarine cable connects to a local
network the island has four of these
locations and they were focal points
during a series of War games run by a
U.S Think Tank last year it explored
what Chinese military action in the
region around Taiwan would look like in
these War Games Chinese teams targeted
taiwan's Landing stations with missiles
and cyber attacks which cut off the
internet in Taiwan and severely limited
traffic for Japan Guam and Hawaii each
time China gained the upper hand because
taiwan's team was forced to shift its
focus away from defense to restoring its
ability to communicate with the outside
world
to repair any damage infrastructure
Taiwan would need help from private
companies and nearby countries like
Japan but security analysts say any
assistance would be unlikely amid
military activity
just take a look at what happened to the
trans-pacific express during China's
recent drills on July 25th this cable
which connects Taiwan to other countries
suffered a failure off the North Coast
of the island about a week later a
Japanese cable repair company dispatched
a ship to fix it but three days later
China's military exercises began and the
ship was unable to fix the connection
it's a questionable if any any
maintenance operator willing to repair
the cable because that's the in the
wartime I believe that would be very
tough for them to do la kind of
maintenance
China State Council information office
didn't respond to a request for comment
about whether Beijing considers taiwan's
cable infrastructure a Target and if it
would allow repairs during military
activity
so Taiwan is looking to protect itself
by adding more connections to the
internet like this new cable called
apricot which is funding for meta
alphabet and Telecom operators in Taiwan
Japan and the Philippines it's due to
Star service in 2024 and alongside
laying more cables Taiwan is also
looking to create a backup with this low
earth orbit satellite systems like
spacex's starlink can provide internet
access without any physical connections
over land or sea during a visit to
spacex's headquarters in California in
July taiwan's minister of Science and
Technology said the island was committed
to continuing its close and mutual
cooperation with the company
taiwan's minister of digital Affairs
said in a statement that the Island's
internet is a national security issue
and the government is allocating funds
to multiple Solutions including 5G base
stations and satellite connectivity
but integrating these options into
taiwan's communication systems could
take years cellular complication is not
something like a program play we need to
make sure when we need it it will be in
place
China which sees Taiwan as part of its
territory has vowed to take back the
island by force if necessary as the risk
of a conflict escalates the Internet is
just one of many strategic resources as
well as ports and Manufacturing that
Taipei is stepping up to protect